we have in gq
just a delightfully absurd profile of
aoc
uh who they're trying to set up to be a
future presidential candidate
here here are just some highlights from
it
she says people ask me questions about
the future and realistically i can't
even tell you if i'm going to be alive
in september and that weighs very
heavily on me and it's not just the
right wing misogyny transcends political
ideology left right center this grip of
patriarchy affects all of us not just
women
men
as i mentioned before but also
ideologically there's an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness
in so many places
and that that might be the truest thing
she's ever said there is an
extraordinary lack of self-awareness
i'm pleased to report what day is it
it's september 8th
we are now more than a week into
september
uh aoc has survived she is alive good
i'm glad i'm glad you could make it aoc
what did she even mean by that i don't
even know if i'll be alive it's like
when she said i was afraid i was going
to be raped and murdered on january 6th
meanwhile she wasn't even in the same
building she was down the street
from from where the the very scary
midwestern grandmothers were where the
florida dad is sipping a coors light in
the rotunda gosh golly could you imagine
there is an extraordinary lack of
self-awareness there is an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness but it doesn't
seem to harm her actually
later on in the profile
gq asks her outright do you think
that you can be president and and the
fear that aoc has the little
hesitation that she has to be president
is the scariest thing of all in this aoc
profile in gq she was asked
are you going to run for president do
you think you could be president she
says yeah maybe
but here's her hold up
she says could obama have gotten elected
without the kind of financial support
that he had
right she she opposes wall street maybe
that'll hold her up then she goes
further she goes i don't know
they say even if she theoretically were
to become president then what she'd face
a system from the senate to the supreme
court
both empowered and inclined to thwart
her most sweeping ambitions
there are still plenty of limitations
she said playing out that hypothetical
it's tough it's really tough so what's
tough
she's saying there are all these
limitations all these impediments
but she's not just talking about
corruption she's not just talking about
popularity she's not just talking about
the big banks and the entrenched
interests
the the big impediment to her sweeping
presidential plans
that that
they are describing is
our system of government
they're saying that the separation of
powers and system of checks and balances
is the big impediment it's tough it's
really tough i've got to deal with a
court
i have to listen to the legislature
i'll have to follow the constitution
and that might impede me from doing what
i want to do what do they want to do
they want to upend the country
the country to them is bad
that's their starting point it's not
that they research the history of
slavery and they discovered america is
bad
but by that model every country in the
world is bad and by the measure of
slavery america is the least bad country
ever
it's not that they looked at the
interactions between the european
settlers and the native americans and
determined therefore that america's bad
it's not that they no they started with
the premise that america is bad
okay and then they formulate our
arguments usually species arguments
to back up that argument but it's it
begins with an antipathy for the country
which they want to upend they want to
upend it fundamentally that's when
barack obama said we're about to
fundamentally
transform america he is expressing a
hatred for the country because you don't
want to fundamentally transform things
that you love
when when aoc says the reason i might
not run for president is i'd have to
deal with that awful constitution and
i'm not sure i'd be capable of upending
the whole system of government that
expresses a hatred for the country and
the form of politics that we have here
her problem is america and she needs to
overcome america to follow her
to achieve her political ambitions
speaking of the judiciary putting good
constraints on demagogues there's a
great ruling just came out of a u.s
district court u.s district judge reed
o'connor in texas has just ruled that a
new rule
requiring employers to provide coverage
for drugs that are called prep drugs
violates the religious rights of
employers under federal law under the
the uh rifra rule
the religious freedom restoration act
this was totally the correct decision
why was it a correct decision though
these prep drugs are drugs that are
taken pretty much exclusively by
promiscuous homosexual men to prevent
them from contracting aids the point of
the prep drugs they're apparently very
effective drugs is if you take them
before you engage in risky activities
you are at a
greatly greatly reduced chance of
contracting aids like 99 reduced chance
of contracting aids so then the question
is who who is at risk of contracting
aids
and the answer to that is
overwhelmingly i'm going to use the the
most conservative numbers possible here
two-thirds to three-quarters of the
people who get aids are gay men that's
that's where the spread is
and then you've also got intravenous
drug users and then you've got then
you've also got people who
who unwittingly have sex with gay men
and you've got and and it's not just gay
men it's not men that just identify as
gays well it's gay men but it's men who
might say no i'm not a gay man i'm as
that monkey pox coordinator was saying
earlier i'm just a member of the men who
have sex with other men community
which is somehow different than the gay
community or the bisexual community or
the whatever but it's all it's all kind
of the same stuff that's that's how you
get aids okay
and so
the question is
the question is not should gay guys take
this drug
it seems like if you're going to engage
in these activities this is
probably going to help prevent you from
contracting this virus that spreads
almost uniquely among
among people who have sex with among men
who have sex with other men
the question is should employers be
required
to pay for this drug
should imp let's say i don't know
catholic school
should a catholic school be required to
pay for a drug
the purpose of which is to make it
easier for men to have sex with lots of
other men because by the way don't
forget we're not even just talking about
men who have sex with one other man that
they know where neither of them have hiv
and then they go get frisky they do
their thing they go do whatever they're
going to do they're not there they are
at a zero percent risk of contracting
hiv
unless they're also reusing heroin
needles on the side they are at a
exactly zero percent risk of of catching
hiv
the risk is only when you are having sex
with other men whose hiv status you
don't know
maybe you're having sex with strange men
maybe you're having sex with lots of
other men maybe you're mixing in some
intravenous drug use on the side and
you're not washing your needles whatever
it is
you're talking about very very risky
behaviors is it right to force
an employer who maybe objects to that
sort of thing on moral grounds like
every major religion ever
to to pay for that and no obviously
that's a violation of people's religious
conscience
obviously this is the right decision and
it was amazing when i when i made this
point yesterday
i mean i made a similar point on monkey
box which is that monkey pox spreads
among gay guys who have sex with lots of
other gay guys that's that's pretty much
the only group that it spreads among
we're talking about 95
plus of the transmission of monkey box
is among promiscuous homosexual men
and you're not allowed to say that
they say that if you say that
it's homophobic
but then they also say that if you don't
want to subsidize all the drugs for
monkey pox for example that you're also
being homophobic but hold on i was just
told the monkey pox is not specifically
a gay thing well no michael it's not
specifically a gay thing okay then we're
not going to subsidize the drugs well if
you don't subsidize the drugs that's
homophobic well it's only homophobic if
it's a gay thing you can't have fit both
ways but they want to have it both ways
what they really want what the libs
really want is just for you to shut up
that's what it's about
shut up take it don't object to anything
because we now have
we now have a new kind of animating
principle for the country and they view
the religious freedom restoration act as
absurd and illegitimate and wrong
and they view christianity as absurd and
illegitimate and wrong and they wear
actual satanic symbols in leather
harnesses from the highest echelons of
government from the white house okay the
people who wear the satanic leather
symbols are the people running the show
and to pretend that that has nothing to
do with christianity to pretend that
that has nothing to do with religious
rights
is
absurd
and it was a lot easier for the libs to
make that argument and just to pretend
that there was a kind of secular neutral
ground where oh come on just get your
religion out of here it was a lot easier
to do that
before they became so overt before
senior government officials
were
leading men around by callers men
dressed up as little dogs that they were
going to abuse in sort of sadistic
sexual rituals and wearing pentagrams
and giving fiery speeches calling half
the country evil in front of in front of
what looks like the gates of hell in
front of very dark backdrops with deep
red lights where you talk about the
battle for the soul of the nation all
right we're gonna have a battle for the
soul of the nation let's do it man let's
talk about the soul
let's talk about morality we have to do
it that's what they want it's amazing
sometimes you'll hear this from the libs
all the time they will say why are you
republicans
so obsessed with other people's
sex lives their private sex lives
they say okay how did this really play
out because the way i saw it i was just
kind of going about living my life you
know having to have a nice life and
everything and then the lips come in and
they say hey
hey we're going to
put gay porn in your kids schools which
they actually have done it's a book
called queer and it's gay pornography
we're going to put in your kids schools
for very very young kids often by the
way we're going to um we're going to put
your really little kids like
five-year-olds to eight-year-olds uh in
a transgender indoctrination classroom
and maybe even put them on puberty
blockers and not even tell you about it
in some cases we're going to have drag
shows at the public libraries uh we're
going to
radically redefine marriage
we're going to do x y and z does that
sound good
and then the conservatives and the kind
of normal people they'll say
um
no
could we maybe not maybe not do that and
then the lib say why are you so obsessed
with sex
why are you so upset well i'm not you're
just you're forcing all of this on me
all the time and on my kids and in
public and the pride parades with
probably the monkey pox secretary
dancing in the weird leather on the in
the middle of the street and i just
think maybe maybe we chill with that a
little bit
why are you so obsessed uh we're not
we're not i'm so glad you like that clip
look we hit a million subscribers that's
great i want to go 2 million i want to
go 5 million i want to go 3 quadrillion
ring that bell get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]